[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody yeah we are here again
wednesday night well today you have your
sexual tyrannosaur hat on uh no it's
it's no it's the black one it's not the
[ __ ] tiger striped one tiger stripe
one that's the real section with
tyrannosaur hats well what's that one
called this is kind of like the gothic
tyrannosaur hat the gothic it's more
gothic yeah i guess sorry i just
pictured like a t-rex with like a
[ __ ] yeah a little black outside
it's like that shirt it's kind of sexual
in a leather daddy kind of way it's kind
of sexual yeah it's kind of
a little bit we don't know we don't know
we're just letting it roll okay
i went down to the oasis i had i had two
drinks at the oasis before i started the
show today
but um it had like some of my favorite
bartenders were there and those girls
[ __ ] pour me doubles so it's kind of
like i have four
but i'm good i'll be able to make it
through so you're just warning everybody
ahead of time everybody in case you get
like ornery i'm not gonna get ordinary
ordinary i'm not gonna get i'm gonna
ordinary i'm gonna get over there i'm
gonna get ornery i'm a good move
good mood i cooked and everything fed us
a pizza before the show jen's like we
don't have the time to eat pizza well
because you just came in i just kind of
thought no
because he was like he came back at like
5 30 and i had a [ __ ] he's like well are
you hungry and i was like well ky a
little bit yeah like but we really have
to hurry so i thought he was just gonna
like make a sandwich or something like
that and i was like oh i'm making a
pizza and i'm like dude i'm gonna have
to wait till after because i had the
pizza stuff prepped right i know it was
ready to go everything's ready to go but
the thing about it is that like it's not
so much like the cooking time it's like
then i have to eat it and then like i
have to like cram it in my face really
fast while i'm trying to like get ready
and reread my notes and all that kind of
stuff and i can't really i don't really
get to like relax and enjoy it i had
that pizza ready in 15 minutes i always
have to like cram it in my face and i
don't really like it everybody's
everybody's piling in now everybody's we
almost got 20 i'm in there now that's
good that's like that's a lot for this
little bitty show well yeah i mean well
you can say that but a lot of the
channels that i like on here only have
like half of how many we have so yeah
true i mean we're kind of like a
mid-tier one right guys yeah i guess so
today's gonna be a good show because
this is gonna be about frogging with the
ph
frogging with a ph and it's about people
that sneak into your own house and sneak
into your house and live in your house
without you knowing it
i've only heard of it happening in japan
but we'll we'll see jenny's dug out some
other cases i got a bunch of cases okay
i mean most of the stuff it's not like
super complicated and what i did i
originally was just gonna stick to five
but then i was like well some of the
ones weren't really all that detailed
and stuff and i was like well they
probably won't take that long to
delineate everything that happened and
there was some other ones that i wanted
to include
and so what i did i kind of put them in
a rough order of like least to most
horrifying you know what i mean so it's
just kind of like there's ones at the
beginning where it's just kind of like
creepy because it's inherently creepy to
like find out that some [ __ ] is
like living in your house and you didn't
know
um
to a point where like later on where
like it went into like actual murder you
know what i mean so uh so yeah it sounds
like something that couldn't happen
but it just it doesn't we'll see some
out of horror movies i think that's kind
of why um
when like i cause i guess lifetime has a
show now called frogging hider in my
house or whatever i was gonna watch some
of them today but it's just like um
you can it's streams on hulu but you
have to have like the hulu add-on that
has like live tv like before you can
watch it and i was like well i don't
really have that so i kind of found a
blog that talked about a lot of the
episodes so i pulled some of the stuff
from there and then like i found some
other cases like around and none of the
ones that i'm talking about i'm pretty
sure all the ones i'm talking about are
u.s maybe a couple are uk but i think
all i think one of them's uk but i think
all the other ones are us
so i think for a long time people
thought it was just like an urban legend
because there have been like the you
know the famous viral video that went
around like the japanese guy and it's
just like because a lot of people
thought that was fake yeah no it's true
and i think well no i don't know if it
is i don't think anybody knows if it's
true or not i was living in the closet
but yeah i think it is real well some of
the stuff has been shown to be fake
though where like people were just kind
of like doing that but so you if you
just like videotape it you can't tell
like if somebody's just like fake or
whatever but i heard a story that there
was a woman that was living in somebody
else's apartment up in the cupboards for
it and there was a secret passage she
was using and she was in there for a
couple years that's the one i was
thinking of maybe a year or so they
finally caught her
but she had a little cubby hole in a
little space and she was living in there
and while the guy was out and work at
work she would come out and use the
bathroom take a shower
go do [ __ ] and she knew everything about
him
most of the cases i found and i think
this is probably you know i'm not going
to say like across the board because
there is a possibility that maybe
somebody could be living in your house
for like a really long time without you
knowing about it but almost all of the
cases that i found
uh it was always like a pretty short
amount of time like it would be like the
person was in there for like a few weeks
or a few days or something like that
before somebody was like is there some
[ __ ] in here you know what i
mean um where's all my food going why is
like you know what i mean so uh so i
think it would be i'm not saying it's
impossible i'm just saying that if
somebody said oh somebody lived in their
house for like two years i think it's a
little less likely
unless you lived in a massive house and
there were parts back in the 90s i
remember hearing on the news
or maybe it wasn't the news it might
have been something like [ __ ] uh
might have been unsolved mysteries
that somebody was living in somebody's
attic but there was a way in it was kind
of a country house
yeah you got on top of the roof you
could access
like a ventilation window type deal that
was up in the attic you know what i mean
and he crawled in there and was he had a
sleeping bag and a bunch of supplies but
he got into the house from the outside
by getting on top of the roof
and yeah i've heard about that happening
living in the attic but they never did
catch the guy
because uh the homeowner found the guy's
little camp
up there up in there like his sleeping
bag and all his stuff and never came
back for it
well yeah he probably was just like oh
man something happened to him he never
came back
well i think if i remember correctly and
it's been a while since we talked about
the very famous hinter kaifak murders in
japan which happened like oblate not
japan germany those are two completely
different countries
not even on the same continent what the
[ __ ] am i talking about i think because
i think because i well no because i saw
somebody wrote japan there so i was just
like thinking of that but uh yeah so
those murders which when did they happen
in the 20s or something like that um and
it was like a farm family and they
suspect that the person that killed that
whole entire family had been living in
their house for a little while
but i don't know if they know that for
certain or not because it was like such
a long time ago and he like yeah if he
did he lived up in their attic and he
would like come down and like read their
newspaper and [ __ ] like that like while
they were yeah you know i mean which is
like super weird hugo said there's a
story about some guy who was living in a
mall
that sounds plausible
yeah i saw one i didn't really include
it because i kind of wanted to stick
more with people's houses because i
thought it was creepier but i did kind
of i did find one story i didn't i just
kind of skimmed it but it was about a
woman anna
and her daughter
who were living in a museum yeah like
and they would come out after and i was
like that'd be kind of awesome
[Laughter]
go into like the restroom or something
and crawl up inside uh up inside and
then like after it closed you could come
out like right
yeah so that i think that's what they
were doing because they didn't have any
place to live which like i said you know
i don't know that doesn't really bother
me all that much as long as you're not
doing anything like [ __ ] sinister
like [ __ ] watching people while
they're sleeping and eating their food
and all that kind of crap you know i'd
imagine the easiest place to do
something like that would be a theater
a theater would be easy to live in you
you pay to get in
and then you hide and let it all shut
down
yeah and then you could sleep you could
sleep in certain places you could
actually go in to the theater itself to
[ __ ] sleep during the day
which evidently they were doing that in
china
people homeless people in china japan
yeah they would just buy a ticket and go
in because it was cheaper than a hotel
go in and watch them move and fall
asleep in the damn theater
yeah i mean in front of the movie and
they could stay there for [ __ ] you
know
seven or four or five minutes yeah i
mean if you paid for a ticket yeah then
nobody could kick you out no one's going
to kick you out because you're going to
pay to go to sleep yeah
and then when when it closed you left
you didn't stay there overnight you
slept there during the day during during
all the showings yeah
so you had to be kind of nocturnal
well i i imagine if you're homeless
depending on where you are it's probably
better to like sleep in the day time and
then like yeah actually like walk around
at night because if you're sleeping
somewhere at night depending on where
you live like you'll get busted or
you'll get robbed or murdered or
something like that evidently there are
a lot of homeless people in japan that
that when you look at them you wouldn't
know that they were homeless they
kind of have jobs but they don't have a
home
yeah
so um they'll go to like internet cafes
that have like a private room
and they'll go in there and they'll rent
it because it's cheaper than a hotel
room and sleep in it and take a nap in
there take it happen there's
five six hours and then leave
yeah
i mean you know it's on it's almost kind
of tempting because you're like wow you
don't have to pay any bills
[Laughter]
it would be a pain in the ass i'm not
saying that but because you can only
have what you're carrying on you yeah
you know
you got to do all your [ __ ] laundry
in a sink
yeah i mean
like a public safe and then you gotta
[ __ ] pack it up the right way and let
it dry
i mean if you have the money and you
lived in a city you could just like go
to a laundromat or something but they
did they did it in a sink they go to
like a place it was like a cafe yeah
because they only have three or four
changes of clothes every time they came
out of one set of clothes they just
watched watch the other watch that one
in a [ __ ] sake
you know what i mean roll it up and put
it back in their pack and when they got
somewhere they'd let it dry out
yeah you know what i mean they just as
they change clothes they wash to the
[ __ ] pair that came off and they were
using the soap out of the soap dispenser
you know what i mean it
at like the the coffee shop
but you know they knew how to do it yeah
well yeah i mean you know you got to
find ways to work around [ __ ] you know
yeah they were interviewing one girl and
you know she was cute girl
and uh she's a part-time prostitute in
japan
she wasn't legal or anything she was
just you know blowing dudes for [ __ ]
extra cash and then sleeping in internet
cafes and doing her clothes at the cafe
and [ __ ]
but she was living off of [ __ ] you
know
less than fifty dollars a day
you know
that's ridiculous but you know
less than fifty dollars i don't know
fifty dollars a day is a lot of money
yeah but not in japan
not in japan not in japan and she's
paying
she's paying kind of like rent
you know yeah
not really she's going to sleep in an
internet cafe
well a lot of people i i knew some
people that lived in their cars for a
while yeah you know what i mean if you
got a car you can like sleep in there
like at a rest after yeah
uh samantha said oprah did a show where
the guy dug out the back of an armchair
and was hot and someone was hiding in
there
i got a good i got a good ability to
like sense presence people shifting and
breathing and moving i don't know if you
could get it i mean you'd have to be
real quiet be like get somebody's like
all folded up in somebody's arm chair
like
you take the like what if they farted or
burped or something yeah human beings
make a lot of noise they especially you
and if you
you
have
yeah
if you had a if you had an animal like a
cat or a dog they'd instantly detect
yeah they'd just be like there's
somebody in there
[Laughter]
they would know that's what i'm saying
so i don't know it's just it's funny
because
you know how sometimes and if you have
cats or dogs everybody knows that they
do this sometimes and it'll break you
out whereas like every now and then the
kitty will be doing something and then
all of a sudden she'll like look up at
the ceiling like
really intently
and i always kind of like tease her
about it's like are you seeing ghost
pokey are you saying ghosts
um you i was like you can tell me but
maybe there's somebody up and living in
the attic
i was thinking about it today like when
i was doing when i was reading all my
notes over like making the notes for
this show
i was like would it be possible
for somebody
to live in here like to live in our
attic without us knowing about it
in here
could they get into our attic for i mean
i know the attic entrance
is in right here in this closet in my
office closet
i don't know if there's a way to get
into it from outside because this house
is two stories but it has
has awnings it has awnings and stuff
like over the windows so i kind of feel
like
if somebody had a ladder
you wouldn't even need really that big
of a ladder you could get like onto the
awning part and you could climb up and
like i could and get i can visualize how
that one guy was getting on the roof and
that one yeah you're talking about first
of all it had pine trees everywhere and
it was next to a
a like a hill
you know what i mean so you could climb
up a tree and climb down a branch
and from one of those pine branches get
onto them an awning and get on top of
the [ __ ] roof after you went through
a couple of them you know that's how the
guy was getting up there
yeah i remember that yeah and he he
could get into a
it was like a window looked like a
window but it was actually for mo it was
like a fake window for ventilation and
he was going in that way
he'd be in the
he was in the damn
attic
it wasn't really an attic it was the top
of the roof you know i mean there was
there was uh
there wasn't any floor he had made a
floor and put a sleeping bag there and
had all this stuff he had a little
apartment in there he's getting it from
the outside
because i don't you could get down into
that main house when people weren't home
he was eating in there yeah because i
don't actually know if you could get
into our attic from the outside can you
no
i mean i didn't think you could but i
mean you've been up in that attic
there's nothing there there's nothing
out there there's no openings oh okay
there's no openings but in that
particular house i'm talking about there
was an opening yeah i've seen ones where
that were that was the case like false
windows and
vents that would open and [ __ ] that's
how he got him i mean in my old house
like the one that i had in daytona it
was only one story but there was there
wasn't an attic but there was kind of
like a crawl space up there and like we
didn't have any a person living up there
but we did have a family of raccoons
that lived yeah raccoons get up in there
so that's why they stopped all that [ __ ]
a lot of times and then these people had
to do with raccoons yeah because animals
get up there like move in like hey this
is a nice warm little spot yeah and
they'll piss and [ __ ] up there and
[ __ ] it'll eventually kind of just
damn seep through the [ __ ] top the
ceiling tiles and [ __ ] fall on your
bed and [ __ ] you're like what is this
smelling it i don't know what this is
tasting
you tasted it i would imagine that
whatever raccoon poop smells like it's
not really something that you would
immediately put into your possession
kind of leak is that
in fact anything that leaked out of the
ceiling i'm not putting that anywhere
near my mouth i'm probably not even
touching it to be honest with you
so i don't know why you immediately
think that i mean all animals all
mammals poop like smells pretty much
like hyena you you're crazy
because
yeah okay i specifically remember you
said eating some raccoon poop at some
point
i specifically remember a case
where it's strange a strange
bluish blocks of [ __ ]
frozen [ __ ] you know ice
oh i know
i know what that is and people couldn't
figure out what it was and some people
tasted it trying to figure out what it
was
it was the [ __ ]
the
porta
poop from the place from the airplanes
yeah and it [ __ ] fell out it came out
through looking they ejected it and it
froze
yeah i mean that would be the first
thing i would think of to be they were
tasting them trying to figure out what
it was well see that well you know we
have a word for those people and it's
morons yeah it's blue something falls
out of the sky yeah it's frozen my first
thought is like let's eat that
with some kind of magical ice you know
what i mean
do you think you're [ __ ] yukon
cornelius or something like that going
around those little pickaxes and going
like that and then licking it like to
see if there's gold in there what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] why would that even
occur to you
to like to lick it
i have no idea the 70s
it was a seven that's no excuse well
although maybe it is an excuse because
look at the [ __ ] [ __ ] they were in
the way they won their parents stuff
it's just random [ __ ] falls out of the
sky let's eat it they thought it was
paranormal
even if you actually
i would argue that even if like maybe
even more if you thought it was
paranormal that's even more of a reason
not to put it in your mouth no not the
70s they're thinking they're they're
thinking [ __ ] they've been listening
to led zeppelin they're thinking of
misty mountain hop and [ __ ] elves and
[ __ ] [ __ ] gandalf you know they're
gonna [ __ ] taste them and [ __ ]
they're gonna get some of that magic i'm
gonna get some magic sky water imagine
sky water in their system [ __ ] you
know oh it's all natural man it's all
natural yeah yeah it's organic naturally
out of [ __ ] bowels
naturally out of a motherfucker's bowels
with well chemicals that's natural too
chemical port-a-potty
you know [ __ ]
7-7-47 it's going to fertilize your
enzymes 737 dropping it's frozen ice
[ __ ] droppings on you i mean [ __ ]
crazy does that even happen anymore no
it would evidently it didn't happen back
then that's what i was thinking i
thought it was like a freak occurrence
it was a freak occurrence
i don't know man i'm just saying that
like some [ __ ]
blue ice fell in my yard that would
immediately be what i would think
what is this that's some poop [ __ ] that
came out of the plane
haven't they ever flown in a plane
before with the blue water jesus christ
it was low information back in those
days i mean i didn't think about it
it was just that was their problem
that's your problem you're not getting
pretty to smell good it fell from the
sky so let's eat it yeah it must be well
no they didn't try it i'm not saying
they eat it
it just the testimony of the case said
that some people tasted it
to try to figure out what it was
yeah it was [ __ ] out of an airplane i
wonder if those i wonder if those people
had to like gargle like forever after
they found out what that was or if they
were just kind of like whatever
[Laughter]
why aren't we talking about this
okay
y'all ready
super chats are a lot super chats are
wide open so if you all wanna [ __ ]
where's zach
i don't know actually i haven't seen
zach appear in the comment section
well not today he was here he was here
yesterday yeah i think although he
didn't come to that end but right now
like i said i'm literally losing losing
my gay fan base
yeah i'm losing my gay fan base yeah i
might have to [ __ ] do some crazy
trickling away i'm gonna have to do some
crazy [ __ ] on instagram i noticed that
[ __ ] like you know uh i follow people
on instagram i'm looking at who
following me is gay men mostly
that's hilarious yeah i got a [ __ ]
becoming a gay icon i'm a gay icon
yeah i can pull somebody i love it i
pull some serious dudes too they [ __ ]
date you know
you know these aren't any slouches these
are alpha gays
alpha gays looking for [ __ ] love
looking for very bad name
yeah alpha gays they got the [ __ ]
mustaches and [ __ ] you know what i mean
i pulled some good gays
zach would be jealous
that these are like the ones that zach's
praying for
he's praying for them kind of gays
and that's just falling out of the sky
for me
metaphorically metaphorically
falling out of this just like the frozen
poop from the plate that's right
that's just gonna be how i like
connected yeah i'm like i'm like
it's dad that you know they're asking me
to be gay i'm saying that if i was gay
you lose respect for me they ask you
they're asking you to be please tom let
me tell my story let me tell my story
please tom can you please be gay
we would all really like it
second i go gay all those dudes would
vanish
they don't just vanish they go ah [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
maybe they only like you because they're
just kind of because they know they
can't get it
maybe that's why
everybody wants what they can have they
got
they got respect they'll lose all
respect for me yeah yeah i mean you know
he's played
jeffy art said tom loves his power games
power games
there's not a [ __ ] beta among them
not a beta among them power gays
you're a ridiculous person yet i'm just
doing what i have
i'm doing i'm doing what instinct tells
me to do okay
uh i understand how to put on a show
this is all entertainment and
entertainment is always based in reality
you know [ __ ] it's it's realism it is
true it's true but it's all good you
know what i mean [ __ ] you just okay
that's just that's how it is yeah sure
yeah
yeah uh danny rowling said ohio state
university students secret roommate uh
yeah i'm gonna talk about that one okay
that's probably like the second or third
or fourth one or something like that
like i said i got a bunch of cases
some of them are more like horrifying
than others but they're kind of in a
rough like the first ones are kind of
like creepy but not all that horrifying
like yeah it'd be horrifying if it
happened to you but like no one got
murdered or anything but then like they
kind of get creepier and like worse as
they go on like kind of roughly
um yeah stanley carter i got that one in
there too
i mean i tried to get a good
i mean i found a couple that i was just
kind of i watched a bunch of youtube
videos about it and like i found a blog
that talked about the show and it had a
lot of the cases i didn't put all of
them on there because some of them i was
like well some of them were like kind of
samey or some of them like nothing all
that exciting happened so you know what
i mean so i thought it like it wasn't
that thrilling but you know what i mean
but i wanted like a good
i don't know a good
what's the word that i'm looking for i'm
trying i'm trying to yeah i guess
that'll work that wasn't exactly the
word or phrase that i was looking for
don't you hate that i [ __ ] hate that
when i can't you got a feeling that it
has to come out and you don't know what
word it is yeah a good variety of them
well see it's frustrating for me too
because obviously like i'm a writer and
so like every it seems like every five
minutes i'm like yada yada and then like
i have the concept and i'm just like
that word the word that i'm just like
it's here it's there and i can't like
think of it and it's really frustrating
but uh okay
oh before we do that
um i always forget to do this but i
don't know most of you guys probably
know but i'm going to repeat it anyway
is that i started two new channels
one of them is all horror like usual
movies and books
uh and that's called a scare salon and
then scare salon yeah like hair salon
that's scarce
yeah um and it's got like a little skull
with like a little barber thing in there
it's yeah it's cute
go ahead and a little like straight
razor subscribe and i also do a true
crime one called crime and memorial
crime and memorial and uh yeah so
those two so go subscribe to those
because i mean 13 o'clock has like 12
200 something like subscribers and like
the two channel i mean i only just put
them up like a few weeks ago to be fair
but it's you probably only have like a
couple hundred so i'm kind of like
something [ __ ] yeah we can get
her up to like a thousand and then we
can get that [ __ ] monetized
i mean when i'm when i can monetize it i
might move my flickers of fear and tomes
of terror like my book reviews and stuff
i might move them over there i might not
i don't know it doesn't really matter i
mean like you'll still be able to like
watch them it's not they're not going to
change otherwise but i might move them
over there just so everything's like
more focused you know what i mean yeah
i'm kind of one of those people that
kind of likes to have everything like
organized
you know but you know so i have both of
those so if you haven't subscribed go
and subscribe both of them i'm gonna
start i'm gonna put up videos uh twice a
week so the scare salon one
the the videos go up wednesdays and
saturdays and the crime immemorial goes
up mondays and thursdays
so there's going to be another one
tomorrow which is actually going to be
about the redhead murders and then
there's gonna be uh another horror one
going up on saturday so if you haven't
like subscribed i got merch i got all
kind of stuff
but yeah it's super fun
all right so
let's start talking about
some of these cases now this one like i
said nothing terrible happened in this
case but
i put this one in here because i thought
how [ __ ] weird would it be if this
happened to you right
so this happened i think back in 2016.
now this is a guy named davis wallman
now for a few days he'd been noticing
that some weird [ __ ] was going on in his
house where is this uh this was in
seattle yeah actually i don't think i
said but yeah seattle like right around
2016.
he noticed some weird [ __ ] going on in
his house like every now and then he'd
come home and like some of the lights
were on that he was pretty sure that he
turned off
um one time he found like the window
screen like from the bathroom window
like in the bathtub
uh and sometimes when he was at home
he'd hear some weird noises like coming
from inside the house he's like huh i
wonder the weird thing about this guy
and maybe he wasn't home all that much
um i guess he worked for like a news uh
like a tv news station or something and
maybe he wasn't home that much but he
just seemed very chill about the whole
thing he's just like yeah i thought it
was weird but you know whatever maybe
i'm you know maybe i'm just really
absent-minded and i'm just like leaving
lights on or maybe it's animals or
something like that um he just says he
started hearing noises like rummaging
around like above him and stuff
in the attic and he's just like huh
that's kind of weird
but he just starts like living he just
goes about living his regular life
um
until one day when he goes to his office
like he had a home office and he sees
like a light on like underneath the door
of his office
and he's like pretty sure i didn't leave
that on so he goes to try the door and
it's locked
and he's like this is
so funny to me he notices it's locked
and he knocks at the door like his own
office door in his own house
and from behind somebody says like a
woman's voice says jimmy is that you
you're damn
can you oh my god freak out i would [ __ ]
my pants oh my god i mean if i would i
would [ __ ] my pants more if it was a guy
like i would i wouldn't be scared i'm
not saying like a woman couldn't be
crazy and kill you but um you know i saw
fatal attractions [ __ ] at first but well
yeah well i think that's what a lot of
people in these situations like they
make jokes about it's like oh there's a
ghost or a poltergeist because like
shit's moved around and stuff but
you know what i mean so yeah so he hears
a voice like jimmy is that you
and at which point he's like well [ __ ]
somebody's at my house so he calls 9-1-1
now it took a really long time he said
because i saw an interview with him and
he's like look i like the cops and
everything but it took him like 18
[ __ ] minutes to get here yeah um by
the time they got there she had like
[ __ ] off but what happened was he
knocked and she opens the door it's like
this dark-haired woman
and she says
this is my house i live here i've been
here for three days
jimmy said i could live here
we don't know who the [ __ ] jimmy is we
don't know who the [ __ ] this woman is
but she like as soon as he opened the
door was like uh this is my house what
the [ __ ] you doing in here she like took
off and by the time the cops got there
because like i said it took like 20
minutes uh she was already gone and i
don't think they ever
found her
now the guy was like
he's like yeah it was
like i said he was so chill about it
he's like well nothing was stolen or
messed up or anything i guess she'd been
living in the attic for a few days and
she thought that he was gone so she came
down and she was like using his office
like i don't know if she was using the
internet or something
but
he's like well nothing
jimmy was frog and he made a girlfriend
yeah we don't know yeah we don't know
jimmy was living in there jimmy was
probably living in there too hey baby
this is my house and it's like it's not
even his time it is can you imagine this
how [ __ ] weird we sleep up here yeah
i'm gonna keep it safe down there i
don't want to wreck
it there was another case and i don't
and i don't have like notes about this
one because it wasn't exactly like the
same kind of thing but i think it
happened in detroit but it was this
woman and she was a woman and her
daughter and she had a house in detroit
but she left for a year because um the
house was being renovated so she went
somewhere else and while she was gone
like while the house was being renovated
this other woman moved in
like a squatter and she paid and had a
bunch of like repairs done like she even
changed like all the furniture like
changing the furniture occurred
yeah the squatter was paying and like
had like some of the plumbing fixed and
like all this other [ __ ] and then like
the owner comes back it's like who the
[ __ ] are you
and then the woman's like oh well this
is my house now because i paid all this
money to like have
all these repairs done and she's like
yeah that's not how that works
but the thing well yeah well i mean i
saw like an interview with her and she
didn't seem all that crazy but it's like
it's obviously like a crazy idea yeah
and but the weird thing about it was
that it was gonna take so long to get
because the woman had been there so long
and there was all this like weird i
don't know there was like this weird
legal thing and it's like she had to
go through the courts like to get her
evicted and all this other because i
think she knew the woman like the woman
had lived with her like a long time ago
like that was her ex-roommate or
something so maybe that's how she knew
she was gone but so for a long time like
before she got the court order like the
eviction like they like they actually
let the other woman like live in the
spare bedroom until which awkward that
that must have been really awkward like
when you're coming out having coffee in
the morning it's like hey [ __ ] what's
up why you moved into my house and you
changed all my curtains and all the
locks and [ __ ] like that what the [ __ ]
like who's like who thinks that's okay i
don't really know
but yeah
ridiculous it's ridiculous
what's everybody saying
danny rowling said uh the 1941 theodore
edward coney's case was the inspiration
for the gary busey 89 film hider in the
house we still need to watch that
because
i see it i i
what if gary bc is living in our house
right now i think i i think i speculated
about that that pretty easily imagine
him living in your house
with his
[Laughter]
can you imagine like i go in there in my
closet like to get some clothes or
something and then like i see gary
busey's face peeking out of like the
attic yeah not at the attic trap door i
think he's a homeless dude didn't he
isn't he mostly almost i don't know he i
think he was homeless for a while yeah
but
motherfucker's a trip he's got some he's
got some problems yeah
crazy
oh and another one i saw earlier which
is again another one i didn't include
but this because again it doesn't really
count
but there was a guy and i guess it was
like halloween and the guy was dressed
like beetlejuice
and he must have gotten like epically
drunk like at some halloween party or
something and he goes into like some
random [ __ ] house and like
falls asleep in the batter on the couch
i can't really remember juice yeah and
so like the guy who owns the house like
wake and obviously sees beetlejuice like
sleeping on his [ __ ] couch is like
who the [ __ ] are you dude and it's like
and the dude was like he felt so bad
because like he was so drunk he didn't
know he thought he was in his own house
and as soon as the guy because the guy
was mad obviously and he was just like
uh hey you're in some random stranger's
house what the [ __ ] are you doing here
and the guy was like oh my god i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry i'm like wow that was
a good party last night i guess i've
seen a video of
the video like that in the hood
man i've never been so drunk that i
wandered into someone else's house back
back when they had cool [ __ ] on youtube
before they took all the cool [ __ ] off
of it if [ __ ] black dudes in the hood
and he's [ __ ]
he goes i don't know who this
[ __ ] is look at him look at that
[ __ ] he didn't use that exact
thing he's using the n-word [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] right there who is
that [ __ ] he's on my couch here
he's in my house and his second dude on
his [ __ ] couch big old [ __ ] black
dude [ __ ] on his on his couch [ __ ]
snoring just [ __ ] sawing logs he goes
who is this [ __ ] who is this
and he wakes him up and he's like who
the who are you
he goes who is you the guy
and he just rolled over to go back to
sleep shut up this motherfucker's in my
house
[Laughter]
dude i guess he got got the wrong house
walked right well like i said i've heard
that happening before i've heard of that
happening before where like somebody was
really drunk and they came home from a
party and they just like wandered into
like their neighbor's house or something
like that do what they do with the phone
taking the picture was just totally
incredulous he just couldn't [ __ ]
believe it i think he just [ __ ]
believes that
because you wake up in the middle of the
night
and there's a dude sleeping on your
couch and you don't know what i mean
[Laughter]
how [ __ ] weird would that be damn
and especially if he was dressed like
beetlejuice i mean
actually i think if he was dressed like
beetlejuice that would only be like
weird if it was not halloween yeah like
if it wasn't the day after halloween it
would just be like some dude randomly
dressed like beetlejuice like sleeping
in your spare room or something because
he thought it was his house like i said
that must have been an epic halloween
party because [ __ ] man
like i said
i don't think i've been pretty drunk
before but i don't remember ever being
drunk enough to like hey this is like
i'm gonna wander to some stranger's
house i've never i was drunk enough to
try to piss on the carpet that's true i
thought i was in the bathroom that's
true so that's kind of the same thing
because you thought you were in a
different room yeah i thought i was in a
different room
like this just standing there
sleepwalking
dick in hand
and everybody and everybody in the
comments are just like thanks for that
mental image
[Laughter]
jenny was like what are you doing
pissing
on the carpet and i was like huh what i
woke up
oh [ __ ]
i was like you better i'll be pissing on
this garbage yeah i was like
i got to sleep in this room you know i
was trying to see where it was i pissed
never could find it because i did this
but as i thought i was i thought i was i
was dreaming about it
[Laughter]
dreaming about peeing
it's looking funny we're so gross
we're so gross willow is here
hello willow from south korea
she comes here to listen to white people
talk about pissing on the floor
didn't happen willow
i mean potential pissing on them yeah
alleged
i was dreaming that i was
[Laughter]
it's weird
uh yeah okay so let me okay so let's
talk about another somebody slash fred
points out the yeah the movie black
christmas the very famous 1974 slasher
movie uh actually yeah the the main
antagonist the villain has been up in
the
attic the whole time
so you know there's that
uh all right
so
this one was pretty famous because there
was a video of it now the video first
went up i didn't realize the video was
this old but the video first went up
back in 2009
now the video was first posted by uh a
guy named joe cummings now he was an
actor and he lived in uh manhattan in
new york city
and i guess just lately like the video
has started like making the rounds again
because it went viral like back in 2009
but it started making the rounds again
recently i guess because of the new
lifetime show because a lot of people
are like talking about it
um so he thought like some stuff had
been like missing from his house like i
said a lot of people said it was like
food was missing and like things were
moved and stuff so he was just kind of
like what the [ __ ] is going on in here
so he set up it's not a huge place it
was just like a you know a new york city
apartment which is pretty small so he
decides he's going to set up a home
camera system
uh and he lets it run for a few days and
then he checks the footage
and found that a woman had been secretly
living in the cupboard
was she it was kind of like this is one
i think i remember where was this yeah
this was in new york city okay i thought
it was in japan now the cupboard living
up in the cupboards i mean well i think
that there was one in japan but this is
a different case but it's similar okay
what the like i've seen the video and
like the video
it's like in the kitchen there's like a
cupboard but then there's like a crawl
space like up above the thing and so i
guess because you could kind of see your
crawling like in this like an open space
and then like i guess there was a
like some kind of uh hatch or something
and she could come down because it was
like a chair
you know what i mean like she would
bring a chair and like going and stuff
but um yeah so she would had been doing
that so she'd been like stealing his
food out of his fridge also gross and
this is in the video too like she pees
in his sink okay yeah like she gets up
and like stays on the sink faster than
going back then go to the bathroom even
though like i said it didn't look like a
big apartment it's like why didn't you
just like go i don't know she was afraid
of flesh
making noise and like somebody would
hear her maybe but it's like i don't
know she's probably like really paranoid
because i imagine it was like some kind
of building where it's like nobody would
give a [ __ ] a favor toilet flush or
whatever but um yeah so she was peeing
in a sink and [ __ ] like that
so
yeah so
[ __ ]
that's a good question see they never
brought that up
she was she down the garbage disposal
was she ew
what was she yeah was she pooping in the
sink too yeah or was she just holding it
no you can't hold it well no i'm just
saying well if it was just like a few
days you could maybe hold it but
yikes
i think this is a true story
i don't know see the thing about it is
that yeah he posted the video back in
2009
and apparently like i said it made the
rounds and stuff and he said no this is
absolutely true but it's like a lot of
people were like yeah it would have been
easy to fake you know what i'm saying
okay i mean i'm not saying that it was
fake i don't know
but it actually it would be easy to fake
so
yeah so the video actually shows her
like climbing down like after he leaves
for work or whatever
and then she kind of goes down the stool
and gets on the floor and then she goes
into the fridge and it's basically like
actually like she's owned a place she
owns a place she's like going there
getting drinks and snacks and [ __ ] um
and then she goes and like sits on the
couch and watches tv damn and then opens
the fridge again oh what else is in here
like you're gonna foraging around damn
um but then like she heard a noise and
like thought that the the guy was back
so she like runs and hides i think she
like hid behind the couch or some [ __ ]
like that now apparently like he
reported the reported to the police
obviously and that she got arrested and
they said like i said i don't know if
this is true or not but they said that
she'd been living in there for two weeks
now the quote from the guy this is what
uh joe cummings wrote on youtube when
somebody like asked him about the video
he said i have no idea how she got in
there the only way in is through the
window is i'm on the top floor and
there's a fire escape i don't know what
the top floor is i don't know if we're
talking about like third floor fifth
floor 85th floor i don't really know um
which says there is a fire escape the
police think that she was probably
coming in to rob me when i was gone and
decided to stay in the crawl space like
i said i don't know if that's true or
not but it's a very very famous video so
i thought that i should address it
because i think i was most horrified by
her peeing in the sink which gross but
i just i kind of thought it was sort of
funny that she was just like climbing
down from the crawl space and just be
like hey i'm gonna find some [ __ ]
snacks i'm just gonna sit here and watch
tv you can do like in the [ __ ] house
place your [ __ ] odds place that's
like very funny to me i don't i mean
it's not funny if it would happen to me
but you know what i mean it's just kind
of funny all right so uh somebody
brought up the ohio state university
kids and yeah this is the top one we're
talking about now
this happened back in august of 2013.
so you have these two ohio state
university oh my god holy [ __ ] really
lightning
well thunder
well you know lightning happened yeah at
some point but i didn't see it i just
like you know um but yeah so these are
two ohio state university seniors named
brett muglin and mark hartman
and they move into this off-campus house
now initially they were the only ones
living there it was them and it was like
one other guy um named mj
and they were renting this three-story
house
now as time went on um but it was a big
house i guess
and you know it was rented out to other
students so it was the three of them and
then it
eventually ballooned up to like i guess
like 10 people or 10 like between 10 and
13 people were like living there like i
said it was like a big three-story house
now
when all of this was going on they said
at this point we were kind of joking at
first
about like i said we thought the place
was haunted
because
only a few days after we moved in we
started noticing like just we like
little things like um you know we'd come
in that like the cover doors would be
open or like you know the microwave the
door the microwave would be open all
that kind of stuff
um and they kind of they said well we
searched the whole place and didn't find
anything
the only thing they did find was this
door in the basement
uh which was locked and they couldn't
get in like i said they were renting it
so they just kind of figured well you
know it's not their business or whatever
they thought it was just like a utility
closet so they didn't go in there
um
and so they were like well it's either
ghosts or one of us is sleepwalking and
like moving [ __ ] around and like opening
cabinet doors and stuff like that
um
then they started hearing like weird
noises like alarms like i guess like
phone alarms and stuff like that like
going off from behind the door in the
basement
but they and they try to like figure a
way to open it but they couldn't do it
so finally they call the landlord up and
it's like what the [ __ ] like you know we
hear keep hearing noises like from
behind that door
and so they come in there the landlord
comes in and opens the door
and there's a secret apartment in there
and someone has been living in there for
like a really long time they said they
found it was they said it was tiny it
was like a closet
there was like a tv in there there was
like a little there was you know
pictures up on the wall there's like
clothes there's like a little bathroom
um so somebody's been illegally living
there because the landlord didn't know
about it either no hold on let me back
up what
this is a little room where in the
basement in the basement
it's just of a house
it was a house that had been rented out
to a bunch of different university
students so it had been broken up into
like a lot of different like apartments
okay so somehow he re-engineered
something something and made a space for
himself and nobody noticed it yeah in
between tenets or something yeah it had
to have been
well because there were a bunch of
tenants living in there like i said it
was a big house it was like it was
college right yeah so in between college
year
he was able to modify something and get
down in there and so when when the new
year started up and the new batch of
renters showed up
there was somebody living or somebody
already in there and they didn't notice
the change
yeah it was something like that it must
have been that yeah
but yeah so this guy was like living in
this essentially like it had its own
bathroom but it was like they were like
it was a closet essentially it was like
a utility closet like with a little
bathroom off the thing like in the
bathroom with a flush toilet or which i
guess
i guess
well some basements have the little bit
i don't know if it had a shower in it
but it might have had like a little half
bath so that means
that means that there was a bathroom
pre-constructed there and somehow he
usurped it
and walled it off and nobody noticed it
was missing i ain't really buying it
camp guy said it was a real toilet but
it wasn't hooked up to a drain or a
water supply oh okay yeah it was like
one it was like in a basement like i
said okay it's a real toilet hooked up
to his own vert
wasn't hooked up to anything so it must
have been he converted it into a
chemical toilet maybe no i don't think
he did that or maybe he he couldn't use
it it was just toilet there
yeah maybe i don't know maybe i'm just
saying he seemed to know what it was
yeah well this is a fairly this is a
fairly famous case
and the thing about it so
the landlord apparently didn't know this
guy was living there either
so
uh when they went in there actually the
guy that was living there clearly wasn't
in there so they're basically like hey
budge or evicted
um they left like a police note and like
the landlord left a note and everything
like that but the weird thing about it
is that
they you know the photos that were on
the walls like one of the guys the
students that was legally living in the
house he recognized the guy that was in
the photos this who's presumably living
here
um
he said yeah i ran into this guy
like downstairs one day like in the
house but i just thought he was either
another tenant or was like a friend of
somebody that lived here
and he said now that he's thinking about
it he said when i met him the guy said
oh i was wondering when i would get to
meet the people who live here
and he said his name was jeremy and that
he was also an ohio state student
so they said what ended up happening
they found out later was that jeremy had
gotten into the property i guess like
one of his cousins was living in the
house like legally and he got in there
like saying hey i'm visiting my cousin
and then he just kind of like finagled
his way into without anybody like
knowing what he was up to
um now interestingly he didn't hurt
anybody or anything like that he just
wanted a place to stay like without
playing paying rent i'm assuming so he
was just like living in this little room
and actually like the two guys that
ended up what are you doing
is that was that you yeah it was pookie
oh that's what i thought
yeah pookie's like clawing on my chair
yeah i thought she was going to jump up
on here and i was like oh you better not
but uh but yeah so the holy [ __ ]
tornado it is yeah well it always sounds
like that up here like when it's i don't
know why but yeah so the two guys were
basically like well we feel kind of bad
for him because he seemed like a really
nice guy
um but you know he wasn't technically
supposed to be living there so
you know we don't know like you know
they said he seemed like a nice guy but
you don't you can't just have like
random [ __ ] like living in the
house because you don't know like
kind of reminds me of a case i heard
about a long time ago where the actual
landlord got in trouble he had modified
he was rent he sectioned up uh like one
of the floors of his house and was
renting it out the students
and uh he had rent them out
to uh girls
and he had changed the walls now
normally a wall is only maybe about
you know 10 inches thick
his walls were about he changed him to
about 20 inches thick so he could so he
could get into a secret passage in
between the walls and walk down through
them and look through little pinholes
you know what i mean yeah so he had
access and i got a case kind of like
that one he's not the same but
he was spying on his own tenants
and he'd take a little
i guess a little [ __ ]
small [ __ ]
pen or needle or something he'd start
picking holes through the walls and he
could look through it somehow
but uh the cops got his ass
the girls could said he could hear
something moving in the walls they
thought about it but they didn't know it
was him they didn't think there was
enough room in there yeah but he'd be
creeping down through the walls when
their boyfriends were over and they were
in there cracking and he'd be watching
them [ __ ]
i mean sir there's this one
yeah this is before but he was into the
[ __ ] stealing it you know what i mean
and this is before a little miniature
micro cameras he was doing it through
his eye god damn it the house gonna blow
over [ __ ] hell can you guys hear that
feels like the [ __ ] house is gonna
blow up i mean it does it sounds like
that yeah
house doesn't move holy crap
yeah how's it going
that's like a 60 mile an hour wind
well i see i don't know if it is because
i mean just a regular storm like in
florida like it always sounds like a
[ __ ] tornado and i don't know if it's
just this room
like the acoustics in here
or something that's pretty windy is it
yeah yeah well okay hopefully we don't
lose the [ __ ] power that would say
yeah but uh
yeah my my little weather saying thing
says raining now i'm like yeah
we need a whole internet to tell us what
the weather is not
[ __ ] stupid well sometimes i don't
know you know
yeah it's not always this noisy i don't
know it's like it's moody you know it's
like adding like some atmosphere like i
said hopefully it doesn't get too bad
because i don't you know i don't want
the power to go out if hey if you guys
lose us it's because of this [ __ ]
storm i mean we'll come back after after
again we're in florida and this is
florida's monsoon season it rains every
day like i said it does this pretty much
every day like something usually it does
it earlier than this it's a little bit
late for it to be
yeah look it out
to florida yeah
yeah like people like talk about like
how it's always sunny beaches and
everything like that i'm like
yeah but it's like two hours of [ __ ]
foreign it's like this every single day
in the summer in the summer and most of
the autumns yeah it doesn't last long
though it's a couple hours so it's gone
oop
oh oh lost the power oh oh
losing power i think it's still going
yeah it never never yeah well because it
has a battery he's got a battery it's
got a battery it's back although is it
still going
oh oh [ __ ] we're losing power god damn
it look at that look at
what's going on i don't know if it's
still going or not it's gone
okay it's gone i mean like i said my
laptop has battery backup but i'm not
really sure about if we lose the um look
out here make sure
if we lose the um
the wi-fi or the uh
oh okay
jesus [ __ ] christ
hide pokey
should be good
all right should be good
it's still going right yeah yeah okay
it's just a ver okay everything's going
well i'm gonna keep on going we haven't
lost we haven't lost anything sly said
you guys have a generator yes yeah yes
got two we have two generators i just
haven't [ __ ] um spent the one
thousand dollars i need to make a hookup
so i can put
connect both generators to the house
that way i can run everything yes that's
the next thing i got to do that's the
next thing i'm trying to get you guys to
pay for
well
let's just let's just finish paying for
the [ __ ] llama the lawnmower first
buying this house boy [ __ ] sucky
drive i told you i've you've never owned
a house i owned a house before suck your
[ __ ] and i was just kind of like dude
they're money pits i'm telling you right
now yeah it's always something i'm too
old to rent though i'm just going to
[ __ ] die in this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this will be tom's coffin
but die here and [ __ ] have somebody
else [ __ ] take it from me
[Laughter]
don't have any [ __ ] descendants to
give it to
you could give it to pookie give it to
pogi
what is this you don't know that you
don't know
um yeah it's a twister it's a twister
yeah it's pretty much like something
[ __ ]
god damn
that is unbelievable don't believe me
listen to that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
freaking me out blowing the house down
it's freaking me out like i'm trying to
get back to the topic but it looks like
hurricane force winds out there i mean
what else is new yeah
this isn't actually a hurricane is it no
no no it's not a hurricane i was gonna
say
it's the thing about florida though is
just like unless it's like a [ __ ]
category five everyone's like yawn yeah
cause because it does this like a 60
mile an hour wind though because
everybody does this every [ __ ] day
like yeah wake me up when it's like
[ __ ] but you know what i mean but it
could be a tornado so it's like
all right so if it blows away anyway we
gotta get back to the show we're gonna
get back to the show
wait see he's oop dude
it's coming back
what's funny is that the pot the the
light settings come back normally
yeah they don't usually sometimes well
it's weird because the the lights like
the little colored lights and stuff i'm
always just kind of like most of them if
they go off like if the power goes off
they come back like on the settings that
you have but there's always one
[ __ ] one of them
that sits there and like blinks and does
some like weird ass [ __ ] and then i
can't figure out like how to get it back
because it's doing the settings on those
is a pain in the ass yeah it really is
uh blared a dude says sounds like pookie
running a muck on this end i don't think
pookie is causing the storm no pookie
the storm bringer
i told her to hide it
i think she went and ran under the bed
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that's what storm is
[ __ ] this [ __ ] she's like i don't like
this
i don't like it either yeah
all right so let's talk about this next
case so this happened back in 2017.
now this is the kennedy family the dad's
name is jerome and the mom's name was
ashley and then they had a 10 month old
daughter named reagan and this happened
in pittsburgh
pennsylvania so they've been living in
this house for a little while apparently
like quite normally quite happily um and
they start then they start hearing like
these weird noises like above it's like
in the ceiling like over the bedroom
right
and they can't really think of
what on earth that could be
one day in the mid-summer of 2017
jerome's laying in his bed taking a nap
or whatever he starts hearing these
weird like loud noises like coming from
the attic now he's just like i wonder
what the [ __ ] that is probably thinking
it was just animals i mean that's what i
would think but then he sees like um
this light that's sort of coming out of
this pipe in his room the pipe that goes
up to the attic and he's he's like it
almost looked like
somebody was like had a flashlight like
behind there was like looking for a
place to like look through the pipe or
something right
so he's like okay well i'm gonna get to
the bottom of this [ __ ] so he buys a
surveillance camera jesus christ
he buys a surveillance camera to figure
out what's happening in the attic he
buys the camera drills a hole through
the wall um and then kind of like tucks
the camera like up in there
um so basically
they only had to wait for a day or two
um they watched the footage back and the
surveillance camera has picked up
footage of a guy
up in their attic and it's actually
their neighbor a dude named robert
havrilla
i think is how you pronounce his last
name
so
the two of them are just like what the
[ __ ] is this creepy ass [ __ ] but
they i mean they had seen him before
obviously he was their neighbor but he's
just like well we just thought he was
like a dude that kept to himself he
minded his own business they said that
he was quote unquote very reclusive
so basically they're like well how the
[ __ ] did he even get in here
what he did was he had installed like a
removable wall like to come in and out
of their attic
i don't know i don't remember if their
houses were connected somehow but like
he lived next door anyway
so he what he would do was crawl up into
their attic and then like he was looking
into their bedroom and like you know him
like the the husband and wife were like
had the room and then they had a crib
with their 10 month old daughter in it
so the guy was like in there
like watching them yeah all the time
watching him have sex
yeah and like watching the baby and [ __ ]
like that
and so as soon as like they figured that
out they go up there and they found they
not only found like the removable wall
but they also found a bunch of holes
in the common wall so i guess it was
like a um like an attached it's
pittsburgh so i guess it was like a row
house yeah um
so he finds like all these holes in the
walls like between their houses
so he starts like stuffing in the paper
like until you can figure out what's
going on so he like kind of he he wanted
to get all that evidence together like
before he called the cops so then he
called the cops and filed a complaint
now the guy got charged with trespassing
and was stalking
now
so obviously this is crazy to me because
their attorney obviously was just kind
of like well we don't know what the [ __ ]
was that dude like why the [ __ ] would
you like be peeking into your neighbor's
bedroom unless you had nefarious intent
right and it's a good thing that
jerome like saw the [ __ ] doing
this stuff and like called the cops
before something really bad happened
what if he was a [ __ ] murderer you
don't know
um but when they talk to
robert havrilla
he says oh i totally didn't even climb
up into the couple's attic even though
they had camera footage of his stupid
face like i've seen the pictures
it's like they can tell that you who who
the [ __ ] do you think you're trying
he's like i don't even have a ladder in
my house i don't know what you're
talking about um and his attorney like
the defense attorney was like um well he
didn't have malicious intent at all i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] what kind of
insanity happens like don't be crawling
up by attic looking at me while i'm
sleeping [ __ ] off slides here what's up
sly
what's up sly i see you know what i mean
yeah um so yeah
now uh
they i don't think that he got i i kind
of feel like maybe jerome was like i
think he's gonna get away with it
but he did get convicted like he found
guilty of one charge but it was only
criminal trespassing and that was in
july of 2018 and i'm sure you don't
really get much for that i mean that's
like a [ __ ] charge and honestly like
i was looking to see like what had
happened like what the sentence was and
i found
like the um
i guess like the legal
uh or the legal ruling like where i
don't think it was from the original
conviction though i think it was whoops
i think it was from um
an appeal that he'd filed
but i don't know if he like and that was
from 2019
so i don't know if he was only maybe
in jail for like a year or something and
then like they let him out because i
don't really it seems like they didn't
really think it was that big of a deal
i'm like they got they got bigger fish
to fry they do i guess but it's just
like
you keep christmas baseball well yeah i
know but it's like the thing about it is
like you
you need to nip that kind of stuff in
the bud man i mean there's really not
any
conceivable reason
why
yeah why you would be crawling up in
your [ __ ] neighbor's house like
watching them sleep and watching them
[ __ ] and stuff like that that's what i
mean it's like there's no conceivable
reason and and i'm not saying that this
always happens because sometimes peeping
toms are just like they end up just be
they're just like perverts or whatever
but some of those people that started
out peeping toms like ended up being
[ __ ] serial killers later on it's a
numbers game you need to nip that in the
bud yeah nip down the bus there is
absolutely no reason for him to be doing
that i'm not saying that he should be
like locked up forever i'm just saying
we've been through that [ __ ] before it's
a numbers game
most of them peeping time most serial
killers start off as like peeping toms
and [ __ ] like that
but most peeping toms don't become
serial killers that's a [ __ ] no i
know that but you never know like which
one is going to and and honestly if you
don't have room to lock them all up if
it happens to you
right
i don't know you you want some [ __ ] to
happen but the way the cops see it
they're like
yeah we punished him but we can't lock
him up forever we got to let him out
eventually we got all these other bad
[ __ ]
need to be yeah you know i don't know
people that are running around robbing
people and killing them
i know i mean i guess like climbing up
in somebody's attic and like peeking out
through a hole is not like i mean in the
grand scheme of things
is really not all that bad
and he did get convicted of trespassing
but like i said i don't know how long he
served it looked like maybe a year and
then he filed an appeal and i don't
really know because i didn't have time
to like read all the [ __ ] there's
lots
of sex offenders lots of them well yeah
they can't keep them all locked up but
it's mostly stupid [ __ ] like flashers
and peeping toms that's the [ __ ] main
thing
jack off artists
that's somebody who [ __ ] shows up and
starts jacking off on you and you better
run
yeah
it's a forester or you know like or you
know like make a joke about it it's like
oh look it's a penis but smaller yeah
yeah
they got the drive by jack off artists
he's in a car driving by
yeah it's all kind of you know
it's perverts yeah they got sexual
problems
yeah yeah
oh he's busting dennis out
they can't control it you know
she was a little bit they don't have any
she was a little bit upset they don't
have any style they're they're harmless
they don't have any style
well they don't bind torture and kill
like he had so much style oh yeah
i even dress up dress up take pictures
of myself i'm so pretty
i'm reenacting
reenacting role-playing you know
when you have the
when you have x-factors sometimes you
have to you know role-play a little bit
as the minutes or taking pictures as the
minotaur shipping it out to you sharing
with you i'm sure you know i i uh he's a
generous i'm generous i'm a share yeah
thank you devin yeah
we all get [ __ ] good
but i would not i wouldn't know how to
communicate with dennis raider
i wouldn't be able to lead him to say
all kinds of i wouldn't be able to keep
a straight face to be honest with you
because the whole time like i know like
i'm not like you know